so inflation is at seven percent but
what does that mean for you and the
things that you buy well we've been
taking a closer look at some of the
items that experts use to calculate
inflation and we've created a tool to
show just how much prices have changed
firstly there's a big difference between
different items we've analyzed more than
three million different prices for over
500 things and we've found that in the
past five years look at this food costs
up 4.3
services up 15.5 and goods there at the
top up over 20
now some specific items have really
ballooned you might have thought that
getting a bike might help you avoid
those rising fuel costs but look an
adult bike has gone up by more than 200
pounds in the last five years and a
child's bike well that's up by 71
clothes have been another big steep
driver here particularly women's wear
imagine for example you're heading off
out to buy a new sportswear outfit
you've bought shorts trainers and a top
now the top is slightly down on what it
was five years ago but the shorts are up
on average 34.5
and the trainers will now likely cost
you around 80 pounds your total bill
would be up by a third around 30 pounds
the same is true with services imagine
you want to head out for a nice meal out
well almost everything involved with
that has gone up a restaurant dessert
for example is up by 13 on what it was a
lager will now set you back around four
pound 29 and then there are the extras
that you might not have thought of so
for example a two mile taxi fare to get
you there would have cost about five
pound 50 in 2017 it now costs nearly
nine pounds and if you add into that a
main course a glass of wine babysitting
fares which have gone up by about a
third then your total bill for this
night out will be nearly 20 more than
what it would have been and then there's
food it's the one truly unavoidable
expense for people struggling and while
there are some food items that have gone
down in price for example carrots now
costing 57p a kilo of minced beef that's
about 10 lower than what it was many
more items have shot right up just a few
examples here uh a tin of baked beans up
by a quarter
up to 71 pence and tomatoes even more
costing around 2 pound and 83 pence in
total four-fifths of the hundreds of
products that we included in this
analysis have gone up in price in the
last five years and sadly things are
likely to get worse before they get
better our online tracker will be
constantly updated head to the sky news
website to explore the impact on your
shopping basket